s'il y a un sujet qui a jeté une ombre
sur ces Jeux Olympiques c'est cette
fameuse loi interdisant la promotion de
l'homosexualité auprès des mineurs qui a
suscité un tolé en Occident ironiquement
ces jeux vont se dérouler dans une ville
soi qui depuis longtemps est un lieu
très prisé de la communauté homosexuelle
russe nos collègues de la CBC ont visité
le club Mayak qui offre tous les soirs
des spectacles ha en couleur le
propriétaire du club s'est dit très fier
d'offrir à soi un lieu accueant pour la
communutay
G
McDonald's plus du bar dehors DEES murs
ils se sentent mal acceptés se disent
Vic de
préjugésis l'entrée en vigueur de la
nouvelle loi plusieurs militants
homosexuels dénoncent une recrudescence
des crimes aineux dans plusieurs régions
du pays les autorités russes affirment
qu'elles veulent tout simplement
protéger les valeurs traditionnelles
familiales du pays mais parmi les
homosexuel que nous avons rencontré la
réalisatrice Francine Doyon et moi
plusieurs se demandent s'ils ne vont pas
devoir s'exiler pour pouvoir vivre
ouvertement leur
différen
il a pris une arme et a dit je vais te
tuer
15 hommes masqués sont entrés dans le
bar j'ai ét frapp à la
tte je suis persécuté par des
extrémistes homophobes de
droite pour comprendre ce qui suscite
cette vague de violence envers les
homosexuels aujourd'hui en Russie il
faut aller rencontrer Vitalie Milonov
député de Saint-Pétersbourg c'est lui
qui est à l'origine de la loi contre la
promotion de l'homosexualité une loi qui
a été adoptée presque à l'unanimité par
le Parlement russe en juin
dernier nous légiférons selon nos
traditions c'est comme ça que nous
voulons éduquer nos enfants
nous ne voulons pas que nos jeunes
soient témoins de discussions sexuelles
dégoûtantes en Russie l'appui à cette
loi qui pénalise la diffusion de toute
information susceptible d'éveiller
l'intérêt des jeunes envers
l'homosexualité a été massif
l'homophobie n'est pas nouvelle être gay
était considéré comme un crime depuis
l'époque soviétique jusqu'en
1993 et comme une maladie mentale
jusqu'en 99
60 % des Russes estimaient que la
société ne devait pas accepter
l'homosexualité en 2002 ce chiffre a
grimpé à 74 % l'an
dernier mais Vitalie Milonov insiste la
loi selon lui ne brime pas les droits de
la communauté
gay les Russes ne s'intéressent pas à ce
qui se passe dans la chambre à coucher
ils ont tous des droits qu'ils soi
homosexuel ou qu'ils aent un
comportement sexuel
déviant absolument connaissez-vous des
enfants heureux nés de famille
homoparentale sans recours à
l'assistance médic non
JAMA combat des homosexuels est
difficile seul quelques voix s'élèvent
contre Vitalie Milonov celle des
victimes il se fait appeler Adic il a 28
ans originaire d'une petite ville de
province il s'est installé à Moscou il y
a 7 ans il vit ouvertement son
homosexualité ses parents ses amis ses
collègues sont au
courant pour lui l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi marque une rupture parce qu'il a
été agressé TR fois
depuis cette année on m'a brisé le nez
j'ai été battu et j'ai été menacé dans
le métro avec une arme c'est le résultat
direct de cette loi mais il ne baisse
pas les bras nous le retrouvons un peu
plus tard dans un magasin IKEA
maladroitement avec d'autres jeunes il
dénonce le retrait d'une photo d'un
couple gay dans le catalogue de la
célèbre chaîne le geste n'est pas anodin
deux garçons qui sembrent jusqu 3500llar
d'amendeena volovaite elle aussi pour
les droits des
lesbi prix elle PL d'êtrec et menac de
violence homophob sur
internet il réuss à miner notre morale
et à nous faire peur par le Men et le mé
et par
marche
elena est ignante la nouvelle lo ne
définit pas bien le concept de
propagande mais évoquer l'homosexualité
même dans un cadre éducatif serait
interdit les homosexuels en région selon
se retrouvent donc plus isolé plus
[Musique]
vulnéra depuis l'adoption de la loi deux
jeunes filles se sont suicidé à
novibirque
elles étai sans ressources la lo
paralyse le travail des organismes
quient des
les lies ouvertes sont ban personne ne
peut rassurer les jeunes
gay nous avons const dernièrement une
augmentation d'agressivité et de
violence et c'est d à l'inaction
complète du
gouvernement ce qui a permis à des
groupes d'extrême droite de se créer et
ces groupes ont de plus en plus de
partisans des groupes qui
bar
VI em depuis 3 ans particip à une soirée
lorsun commando a faituption dans le
club tout été saag maretrouvé à
l'hôpital après avoir reçu un coup de
bot à la
tête ils ont renversé les tables cass
des bouteilles et agress des
clients plusieurs BL y avait beaucoup
de
per le retour à la présidence de
Vladimir ptine en 2012 avait donné lieu
à d'Imm manifestation une contestation
des jeunes des urbains des libéraux
depuis le président rus pass à
l'offensive pour réprimer les droits et
libertés et séduire ASI une population
lourdement
conservatrice
[Musique]
analy au centre Carn de
Moscou Letien de la majorité des
[Musique]
Russes la tactique est de discréditer la
minorité plus libérale qui défie
l'autorité de lui faire porter l'udieux
de s'en prendre au valeurs traditionnell
Russ lui se désole de la mauvaise image
que cela donne de la Russie dans le
monde avec cette loi la Russie a
vraiment l'air de pays rétrograde la
planète entière a compris pourtant
depuis longtemps que l'homosexualité ne
présente aucun
danger ici la brutalité peut même aller
très loin sous couvert de pour chasser
les pédophiles les néonazis affichent
leurs
exploits bien ré un adolescent propose
ses services sexuels et attire un homme
majeur qui se fait alors humilié torturé
et le tout est mise en ligne en toute
impunité deux hommes aur même été
sauvagement assassinés parce qu'on les
soupçonnait d'être
homosexuel les droits fondamentaux sont
protégés par le
gouvernement
c'est leur problème ils sont mal dans
leur peau ils ne comprennent pas qu'ils
sont des hommes et non des
femmes demanderiezvous au gens s'ils
souhaitent légaliser la sodomie non
jamais aujourd'hui ad se demande comment
il pourrait élever une famille dans ce
climat Mar et préfè rester discrète
elles ont déjà fait plusieurs voyages à
Berlin et prennent des cours
d'allemand
nous pensons partir si la situation
persiste c'est notre dignité qui est
atжеureement dans la situation Act je
songe à quitter la Russie je dois
décider de vivre ici ou bien de
partira elle peur pas pour elle plutôt
pour les autres mais
c'est dans ce contexte que s'ouvr les
Jeux Olympiques une controverse qui a
peut-être surpris l'Occident mais pas
ceux qui la vivent pour eu elle est à
l'image d'une Russie qu'il subissent
depuis trop
longtemps